One of us just needs to say
a complete sentence.
Haha.
Deal.
Let's see you can do it first.
That's the game.
Oh yeah, haha!
Courtney is a Chef.
She is also one of my
best friends
and she's written so many
cookbooks.
Worked in incredible
famous kitchens.
We're so lucky to have
her on the show
making Elizabeth's food.
Let's begin, shall we?
You and I have been friends,
for what, a thousand years?
Oh, uh? Mean, maybe more?
That is to say we've been friends
for very long time.
And food has been a very
big part of it.
We get together with people
and make something
that then fuel and sustains
Mmhmm.
you.
So today we're gonna
make the lasagna.
-The lasagna.
From Lessons in Chemistry.
Yes!
And lasagna is comforting
and loving and requires
a lot of time and energy.
And, uh, ultimately this is
the beginning of
the Elizabeth and Calvin
relationship.
Yeah,
this is one of the first things
he tastes
that Elizabeth makes.
I think he falls in love
at first bite.
Wow, that's perfect.
It's not perfect but
it has the potential to be.
How do you think Lewis
is going to do making it?
You think he's going
to be okay?
I think he's gonna be
good at the assembly.
Yeah.
I think he can assemble.
He can follow directions.
He's gonna love eating it.
He's definitely going to
love eating it.
Haha, yeah.
As will I
and you.
Uhm- definitely me.
We should probably go
make it
soon.
Let's make it.
Before we get started
pretell,
who is your character
in the show?
Oh, I play Elizabeth Zott.
Um, who is a scientist and
then later has a cooking show.
Welcome viewers.
My name is Elizabeth Zott
and this is
Supper at Six.
[cheering]
I play Calvin Evans...
Calvin Evans is a star.
Smart, well to do, famous.
What's not to like?
...is a Chemist
and doesn't really have
a future in cooking.
Haha!
Until today!
Until today.
Right, so we're going-
we're mm-making lasagna.
It's based on the lasagna
from the show
but this is even more
amped up lasagna.
Umm, it has homemade
pasta dough.
The thinnest layer possible,
it's going to be like twelve
it's going to be
like twelve layers.
and lucky for y'all
I went a head
and already
made the dough.
And I also made béchamel
for it.
So we're going to focus
today on
the bolognese sauce.
-Mmkay.
-Okay
Starting now.
Brie I would like you to
do the honors.
Go ahead and oil.
You're gonna put oil
in the pan
and then add the mirepoix.
Everything but the garlic.
So, we're just going sauté
this down.
So, let's go ahead and add
the meats.
How that sound?
Yeah, what kind of meat
is this
you got here?
-Okay.
So, this is another reason
why this bolognese
is so delicious.
This is ground pork,
ground pancetta,
and then we have
ground beef.
Yeah.
So, go ahead and toss
that in the ole pan.
Okay.
Just throw it all in the
trampoline here.
Yeah.
So, your characters
on the show are two very
passionate humans, like
you're passionate about
rowing.
You're passionate about
cooking, chemistry.
All these passions
you have, you also
share them with
each other.
So, how does that deepen
your relationship?
When they meet
each other
and they are able
to talk on this level
about science
in particular
and then when Elizabeth
starts cooking
for Calvin.
Then it creates this
this language.
I mean the first time
they really start to
connect
is over her talking
about lasagna.
At about ninety-two
degrees
the solid milk fat
in the cheese liquifies
and the bonds holding
together
the casein proteins break
but the melt isn't smooth.
Which is why I've been
experimenting with
sodium citrate, so when
the cheese heats...
Proteins separate from
each other acting as
emulsifiers.
Precisely.
I think a big part
that when they meet
and kind of discovering
how Elizabeth
looks at cooking,
is this a great
kind of metaphor
and microcosm
for their relationship as
a whole because
he sees food
as just like sustenance
and brain power.
You have one fork.
I don't entertain.
So then all the sudden
that you could apply
chemistry and
it can be...
You can go into a
real micro lens on it
and kind of like...
they're really nerding out
on it.
Elizabeth and Calvin
are nerds of a feather.
You cooked for me?
I can't promise it'll taste as
good as yours,
but it's edible.
This is a lovely steam
bath we're getting.
It is, yeah, I'm feeling it.
-Getting a nice facial here.
-It's good for your skin.
Yeah.
Every time I cook I'm reminded
of my grandmother
because she would, every
time she cracks an egg,
would take her long
fingernails
and scrape every little
molecule of yolk out of there.
She grew up
-Really?
with the depression and was like...
-With her finger?
With her nail.
-Yeah
And I do that.
I carry that tradition on.
With your long fingernail.
-Yeah.
Do you have a long fingernail?
Just the pinky.
[laughs]
Well and actually lasagna
reminds me of my grandma
because that's what she would do.
She would make it and then like
the best thing was the next day,
the leftovers.
Reheating the leftovers.
[light jazz music]
Now, we're going to assemble.
So the first layer is this bolognese.
And then we're going to
put a layer of noodles.
A really thin layer of the béchamel,
a little bit of parmesan.
A little bit of the bolognese.
And then every third or fourth layer
we're going to dollop
a little tiny bit of ricotta.
And then we're saving the
mozzarella for the very top layer
so it'll be nice and bubbly
and cheesy.
We're going to put it in the oven.
-Thank you.
-Get ready!
-Bye lasagna. See you soon. Bye.
-Bye lasagna. We love you. Thank you.
While the lasagna is baking
I just have a few random questions.
-Mmm hmm.
-Okay.
Um... We're going to start with
one of my favorites.
An asteroid is headed straight to earth.
You have about, you have
about one day.
Got a day.
Yeah.
And you have one meal.
Oh.
What are you going to eat?
Mine would be a baked
potato with a lot of butter.
Fluffed very well.
Okay.
Sour cream, caviar.
That's a good one.
I would do my mom's apple crisp,
with some ice cream.
This is great knowledge to have.
-Yeah.
-It's important.
It's important knowledge.
The most important knowledge
though,
and I'm sorry I have to ask this,
but you know I have to.
Is a hot dog a sandwich?
I forget where you both stand on this.
I know, which is why you got to go first.
You got to just do what's true for you.
And I think that if you have two pieces
of bread with something in the middle of it,
there's nothing else to call it
other than a sandwich.
Yes!
That's what I think.
[sigh]
Brie, do you not agree with...?
Of course I don't agree
with it Courtney!
[laughs]
Of course I don't agree with it.
This has been going on, this has
been going on for years people.
It's been going on for years.
This is the thing that we don't talk
about in our relationship
because this might drive us apart.
-I know.
I love you very much.
We'll leave it at that.
Okay.
[laughs]
Love you.
The lasagna, can you smell it?
-Wow!
-Gosh I can. Wow!
Let's get it out of the oven,
it's done.
Nothing better than smelling fresh lasagna.
Holy moly.
Yeah.
-Wow.
-Look at this. Look at the bubble.
-It's free as a bird.
-Free as a bird.
Free as bird.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Voilà.
-Oh my goodness.
-Look what we did!
-It's gorgeous.
-Mama mia.
-Mmmm.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
[light jazz music]
-Wow.
-I'm just going to go in.
We're going in.
Ready?
Oh my god.
This is so satisfying.
-Mmmm.
-Who does this? Ever?
We do.
Now.
Wow.
-Wow Courtney.
-Nailed it.
That is a superior lasagna.
-Oh man alive.
-We did it.
Woah!
Y'all seriously thank you so
much for coming out,
taking the time to do this today.
It was so much fun.
I love making lasagna with you.
It was the best.
Absolute best, Courtney.
We couldn't have had a better sensei.
Thank you.
[laughs]
Yep.
Thanks Courtney.
Yeah.
My pleasure.
And if you want to learn more
about their characters and this lasagna,
you can watch
Lessons in Chemistry on Apple TV+.
I'm going to take this home.